le truc que tu détestes le plus les gens
qui me font perdre mon temps
le don que tu aimerais avoir et pour moi
des gens qui me font pas perdre de temps
maintenant 50 50
[Musique]
tu enregistres tout
au début je faisais pas ça parce que je
pouvais pas me le payer
mais le temps passant effectivement je
me suis organisé maintenant j'ai des
camions enregistrement
[Musique]
il y a guitare et puis l'autre tu peux
plus faire ça sur scène
guitare c'est des solos de guitare
là après l'autre
90 minutes
et tu peux plus faire ça sur scène
c'est le premier d'une série de 6
doubles compacts
[Musique]
de musique
tu penses pas que tu resteras dans
l'histoire du rock n'ont pas comme un
musicien de rock mais comme un musicien
classique de l'époque du rock
non certainement pas
que ça va arriver
[Musique]
des morceaux de Zappa je vais vite pas
le faire il l'a fait
il t'a pas obéi
[Musique]
que les radios ne joueraient pas
beaucoup joué
même si c'est une star du baseball
dans tes chansons tu attaques souvent
les télévangéliste
tu penses que les gens comme Jimmy
swaggarte ou pas trop Bergson sont
dangereux
je pense qu'ils sont très dangereux
ils sont dangereux pour les gens qui
veulent pas avoir de religion
ou pour ceux qui sont chrétiens
[Musique]
tu joues des chansons des Beatles
tu aimes pas les paroles des Beatles
on a changé les paroles justement pour
parler de Jimmy swaggars
et c'est une façon ironique de parler de
lui si tu veux parce que les gens ils
connaissent les chansons des Beatles ça
leur ils attendent
et c'était la parodie d'une pochette des
Beatles
parce qu'en France on connaît pas du
kakis
[Musique]
George Bush lui par contre on sait qui
c'est lui on sait qu'il est pas du tout
pratique
[Musique]
si un jour tu es appartenu à la CIA
tu peux pas démissionner
tu peux pas oublier ça aussi
on aura un mec de la CIA la Maison
Blanche
en France on a un questionnaire qui
s'appelle le questionnaire de Proust
[Musique]
et on va jouer à ça avec toi
compte de la misère
en Europe
surtout en Espagne sur les lignes
d'Iberia
[Musique]
partout il y a pas besoin d'avoir un
passeportsent pas pour des histoires de
langues
c'est quoi les fautes que tu
pardonnes le plus facilement
[Musique]
les petites erreurs pendant les shows
la qualité que tu préfères chez un homme
le netteté chez une femme pareil
ta vertu favorite
ton
occupation favorite jouer de la musique
[Musique]
un savon
c'est quoi le trait principal de ta
personnalité
[Musique]
tu choisiras
ton plus grand malheur
quand une composition est mal jouée sur
scène par l'orchestre
[Musique]
le truc que tu détestes le plus les gens
qui me font perdre mon temps le don que
tu aimerais avoir et pour moi des gens
qui ne font pas perdre de temps
comment tu aimerais mourir
[Musique]
tranquillement
l'état présente ton esprit
très confortable
ta devise
[Musique]
tout le temps partout sans raison
particulière et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de tube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu